[Music]
go and rest my name and welcome to it's
a very special video today because it's
my our it's our thousand video breath
it's been two years since I started
uploading videos there are of course
some videos that I've taken down because
I just wasn't happy with them but
regardless if you look up there it
should it should say a thousand or two
thousand one I don't like your lake if
you're true bro it says a thousand up
there I'm really excited I'm really
happy about this I decided to make a
little montage like a history thing
going from zero to a thousand videos or
zero to two and a half million
subscribers it's been a long journey but
at the same time it feels so short and
it feels so like it feels like it's gone
by like this like I had so much fun with
this I'm not gonna get too much into it
because the video itself is pretty
cheesy so I'll let you bros enjoy it
there you go
that's station ever and yeah today we're
gonna celebrate cuz I have 100
subscribers oh my the only reason why I
do this
[Music]
you guys are the biggest part of that
light it's because of you guys that this
actually is fun and that's why I make
videos and that's why I'm gonna keep
Wow
this is my hundred hundred video here
thank you it means a lot to me I love
making the this video let's just take it
really [ __ ] easy
[Applause]
like I said I'm gonna miss you this half
a year since I started making videos
have been so much fun and so much
happiness come out of it
I'm so glad that I got to share these
for many people
okay so who should we bring
I think we should call him Stefano
I lost I am stefano my name is ping and
welcome to Friday with let's go
oh [ __ ] just talking through the barrels
I knew it I [ __ ] know it
the barrels but you should know that I'm
really really happy now
I think me and my girlfriend are perfect
together and I love her I can definitely
keep this up as a job and it's amazing I
was it really took the breath out of me
when I realized that I had one job and
I've been looking for apartment for me
with my girlfriend and then I did this
YouTube thing I had no time for other
things thanks to you guys thanks to my
bros I can quit that job and I can just
do YouTube as my thing and that's just
amazing I mean how many people can say
that their job is what they love to do
the most it's it's I just I can't thank
you guys enough for that every nominated
to go home king of the web so first you
people are king of the web like I feel
so undeserved
[Music]
yes but I said went on a trip to the
subway station you better behave sick of
your [ __ ] and you're complaining dad
supposed to be in school I don't care
about school and stupid [ __ ] like that
[Music]
I'm the fatty tonight Amy today it was
excitement I understand shut up
[Applause]
with diligence or Fuquay a broadside
Iike a dog Venna did he pick you up
agree max
[Music]
so much so much you're making me you're
making me watery my you think about oh
what if my youtube channel it goes
really big and stuff like that I never
ever expected one minute and that is
just ridiculous
[Music]
[Applause]
you